[Music]
[Applause]
John morosi MLB Network Insider will be
across MLB networks programming
including extensive trade deadline
coverage next Tuesday that's August 1st
and you got the Mariners twins coming up
this afternoon first pitch scheduled for
1 10 Eastern John kind enough to join us
what's the latest on shohei Otani John
Dan good morning uh for Shoei Otani and
the angels right now they're actually
playing pretty good baseball they've won
seven out of nine and now they have
their playoff odds moving up towards 16
percent uh so what I'm being told by
sources Dan they're going to wait until
this series wraps up in Detroit and then
their weekend Series in Toronto so we're
still probably waiting until Sunday to
know if they're truly buying or selling
wait so it's that tenuous
it's that tenuous it's that tenuous
potentially the most significant trade
in North American Pro Sports since
Gretzky is riding on the next five games
for the Los Angeles Angels and one of
those series will be in Canada in
Toronto right uh right up the block from
Wayne Gretzky's restaurant if it's still
there exactly not too far from Brampton
Ontario where number 99 is from but no
it's it's a great Point Dan and it's
it's one of the more amazing stories in
sports not just what happens with show a
in the coming days but also where he
ends up playing as of opening day next
year and and it really is a global story
that at least from my perspective we
can't talk about enough I it was wishful
reporting like we we like chaos we like
change we like when stars move around I
grew up in an era I'm sure you did too
where your stars usually stayed with the
same team I get the you know capitalism
free market all that but let's look at
this logically if you were going to
trade for shohei uttani first of all the
angels are going to get prospects I'm
guessing so then you got Mike Trout and
you're going to be in a rebuild which to
me doesn't make sense if I'm going to
trade for him he's got a sign with me
but then if I'm going to trade for him
they're willing to trade him why not
wait until the end of the season when
he's a free agent I don't give up my
farm system
I know I have to pay 600 million
I just don't understand the logic help
me understand the logic of this with a
team that would trade for Otani we'll
start there and then we'll go to the
angels sure Dan it's a great question
and I think at the outset I'll make
clear that there's a pretty big gap
between the Angels being willing to move
him and a trade actually happening okay
because to your point for the angels to
move a player of this caliber especially
when they're playing better
you're going to have to buy them out of
the chance to contend with show a for
the balance of this season and very
importantly Dan to potentially see him
hit home run number 60 in your uniform
let's reflect on that photo for a moment
and how many places that photograph will
hang for a long time home run number 60
or Beyond
for Chalet Otani and the value to your
brand in doing that so I think the
reason why you bring them in now is
because he does have a manifestly
massive impact on your brand on your
team he may well be the MVP so it's
certainly the type of rental player and
impact you go back and think about the
08 Dodgers and how Manny Ramirez changed
that team it's that kind of of an impact
that the middle part of the season but
Dan to your point for you to make this
trade you have to be quite sure that
you're already going to the playoffs and
you'll have him potentially make you a
World Series team and also that you
would have two or three of the top 100
prospects in the sport to make it worth
the Angels while that is a really narrow
road to turn and navigate and one of the
reasons why I still think the odds are
likely that Otani stays in Anaheim
through the rest of this season yeah I I
I'd like the possibility of chaos here
but I understand the logic of just the
business side of this I can't trade for
him if I don't know if he's going to
resign and if he wants to go to market
which it sounds like his agent wants him
to go you know saying he's earned the
right to be a free agent I'll just wait
if I'm the Dodgers I don't have to give
up my farm system or if Tampa Bay wants
to get in Baltimore I think you've
talked about maybe the Diamondbacks is
it going to be an American League team
if ohtani would be traded
would it be an American League team he
would go to you know Dan it's a great
question I don't think it's necessarily
the case I think that broadly speaking
we could see an NL team get him uh and
you mentioned a few teams that are
really intriguing uh like the Rays like
the Orioles like the D-backs those three
teams in particular are better than
expected this year and he could make a
massive impact on them for a couple
months and if he helps them win a World
Series if he helps uh if he gets himself
to 60 home runs in that uniform we have
to take a bit of a step back and say
show a is a global icon in the way of
let's borrow from a different sport
right now think about what Lionel Messi
is doing right now for soccer in South
Florida and in our country broadly
speaking the kit that he's wearing in
Miami is instantly with a couple weeks
worth of games becoming one of the
fastest selling bits of sports
memorabilia in the world now show a and
Messi are different in some ways but the
global Sports comparison I think is
appropriate here to where if you're the
Rays the Diamondbacks
um the Orioles the chances of him
signing with you next year are quite
remote because I do think the Dodgers
have a pretty good home field advantage
there so this is your shot to have your
messy moment is right now and and there
certainly is a reasonable price to be
paid to have that chance
baseball got rid of the second trade
deadline right remember when a player if
he cleared waivers then you could still
trade for them after the first why did
they get rid of that second trade
deadline and Dan it's really interesting
and of course Justin Verlander helped
the Astros win the World Series six
years ago with a August 31st trade there
used to be the waiver trade deadline
that effectively existed at the end of
August baseball wanted to eliminate the
the uncertainty and often the confusion
that came when we would report on trade
waivers in August there was a lot of
there's a lot of opaqueness about what
that meant for a particular player so as
a result it's more of a unified idea
it's July 31st or in this case August
1st but Dan there are a lot of people in
the industry who would like to see this
trade deadline be a little bit later
because what what you have now is the
one unified trade deadline and now
because of the expanded playoffs more
teams that are on the bubble and not
really sure about their Direction the
angels and ohtani that's one case but
the Cubs are in the same conversation a
number of other teams are as well and I
think it's it's certainly a big topic
for a lot of GMS around the sport to
maybe have a little bit of a later trade
deadline in the future talking to John
morosi Baseball Insider for MLB Network
the Aaron judge injury injury first it
was seemed like oh he just stubbed his
toe and then all of a sudden he did more
than stub his toe and then we're still
waiting for him to come back and maybe
he comes back as early as this weekend
but how did we get to this point with
Aaron judge's injury that it took him
this long to realize that he had a
fracture there right Dan it's a really
difficult situation for Aaron and for
the Yankees overall and to your point
it's been almost two months since he's
played a game for the Yankees and in
that time the American League East race
has changed significantly the Yankees
have fallen back they've Fallen all the
way to the bottom of the division uh and
and now what we're not so sure about is
to what extent he is going to be
impacted by this for the balance of the
Season uh how it'll be handled in the
off season what we know is that time is
very short and maybe there was initially
some swelling in that area that made it
difficult to fully discern what was
going on but clearly for someone who
prides himself on being in the lineup as
often as Aaron is he's such a
professional player Dan on and off the
field and I know this is just aching him
to miss this amount of time and to see
the impact on his full team without him
I think it's had a huge impact on
Anthony Rizzo had a huge impact on DJ
lemayu they're simply not the same team
without him and if anything Dan it's
really underscored why he was
um the right choice as the MVP last year
he was worth all the money they spent on
him during the off season as well also I
think this is right Mark McGuire may
have gone through this but if Otani
would get traded to the National League
then that he wouldn't win the MVP uh
they wouldn't combine his stat like
there's no way he could be the MVP
because he would then be traded to the
national league so his stats would only
be attributed to the second half of the
Season or in August on in in the NL is
that correct right Dan so so those two
awards are voted on separately by the
baseball writers in each individual
League uh but one thing we've known Dan
and I'll say this ohtani would be
eligible for the award in each league it
would be up to each individual voter and
I've been one in the past to decide if
he had done enough in either four months
or alternatively well let me ask you
that though John let's say he's traded
next Tuesday
who would be your MVP in the American
League at the end of the season
I I let's put it this way I would still
consider him because let's think about
this it's it's four months of Elite
Performance in two disciplines Dan so I
I would have to say this right now the
MVP in the American League is Otani and
will be ohtani until someone proves
otherwise and and could adley ruchman if
he catapults the Orioles to a a division
championship as The Catcher And and the
anchor of the lineup yeah there's a
compelling case there if Bo buchette
gets the Jays of the playoffs playing a
great shortstop although he's he's
scuffled a bit offensively in recent
days there is not an obvious second
choice it's not like last year where it
was judge orotani and you were happy
either way or even the year before when
it was vladi or Otani that was an
obvious one too there is not a clear
error apparent Dan and if there's one
thing we know for sure with Otani all
the rules that we used to think were
sacrosanct no longer apply
thank you John that's the first time I
think sacrosanct has been used on the
show Paulie yeah that's confirmed all
right thank you John uh that's uh John
morosi we appreciate it John Baseball
Network Insider they got baseball coming
up today Mariners twins first pitch
scheduled for uh 110 Eastern I mean he
made it sound pretty tenuous like these
next two Series Detroit and Toronto
and let's say the angels
only have a couple of wins
I don't see him moved I don't I just I'm
looking at the logic of this it's too
complex to do it just there are too many
moving parts